[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you're feeling abandoned you're feeling
lost you're still now sort of at the
prime mentally with this with this
hatred this dehumanization
um now what was there already was there
uh um an influx of uh Muslim refugees or
people coming coming into Muncie is that
or was there always a community there
well yeah see that's the thing there
always was a community there uh they
never stood out to me really
uh and and and with Muncie you know it
had been a mailing address for many
years really more than anything because
I had broken time
I had two years between the Marine Corps
and the army uh where I tried to be a
civilian that was a bad idea I'm lucky I
made it out alive but I went I joined
the army and and I had already came to
Muncie I came to Muncie to fight
I was trying to make it as a kickboxer
and then I slowly got into the cage and
you know because of drinking and
womanizing that never panned out I
ruined myself you know I could have I
was good
man I don't know if I was UFC good but I
was good I get it you know and uh but
yeah so I I killed myself though I lost
that window so I went into the army
and um
they uh uh they were more than happy to
take me in took me in and you know they
was like I got it you know hooked up
with a a really high speed unit and you
know became an operator again and man it
was off to the races did some great
things man some fun things you know it
was hunting down war criminals in Bosley
and o4 right and Afghanistan and Iraq
and and and oh my gosh it was just it
was
it was incredible but you know now it's
all gone man it's like hey I have
nothing you know I I got money at the
time I had plenty of money actually you
know and and so I didn't really need to
do anything
so I have all this time to think now
about all these people who ruined my
life ruined my destiny stole it from me
bam I got some Muslims right here I take
care of them do one last thing for my
country
make that stand that we are not going to
take it anymore
right
so I took my time I devised a plan it's
over the course of probably a couple
years you know
uh what was the plan to to
um
put a bomb together
simple bomb
and uh
do my best to level the Islamic Center
when I first looked at it when I first
started doing the Recon for it they
didn't have the location they have now
they were actually in a house
that was right off of campus and was in
a residential area
so I slowly kept kept with the process
of putting a bomb together but
waited because I didn't like that idea
because there was too much
there was too many Americans around
I didn't really want to hurt the
Americans right
not that almost everybody inside the
Islamic Center was actually in America
so
um
so I backed off a little bit then they
moved
and they kind of got this out of the way
building
you know it was still close to some
other and I knew there would be some
some residual harm that was going to
happen but I think it would be minimal I
I I tried my best to as best I could in
the knowledge I had about explosives to
make this so it had as little impact on
these other people as possible and it
just went into motion full gear and I
was ready to just all I had to do was
it my my plan was on a Thursday night
late night I had a place for it I
already did that Recon and I was just
going to set it down and wait for them
to have their service the next day in
the afternoon
set across over at that bank
dial it in
do you remember exactly where you were
when you got that impulse when you got
that idea do you remember how it started
I mean was there a process that went
from sort of an idea into I'm actually
going to execute this and
hmm
honestly I don't think so
I think it was just
this is what I'm doing I mean you know
okay ah good idea let's do this you know
kind of like when you when you're at the
supermarket and you and you're checking
out and you see oh man I really want
that Twix bar you know what I mean uh
and and it was good simple yeah and
that's that's what a lot of my shame
comes into into being it's it's it's not
the act itself it's it's what went
behind it that made it so just
yeah this is what I do you know yeah why
did you look at them as the cause of of
you being in the situation that you were
in I think it just had to do with my own
personal experience with being overseas
and and and fighting these Muslims right
uh having them try to kill me you know
uh it just turned me against the whole
the whole group it's like yeah so one
tries to kill me they all want to kill
me you know is that that mindset so it
it's basically it's the basic premise of
how Prejudice builds right of course you
know we see the actions of this one
person because the color of the skin or
where they come from all they're all
like that right
um and
it it just it just kept building just
kept building and
they're all evil every one of them even
the babies did you have experiences
overseas where you saw you're fighting
alongside of of Muslims or you saw
something that you respect or you did
you have any experience before what
we're going to eventually get to you saw
beauty within within the the Muslim
faith
not the faith necessarily
the people
um you should tell the story about that
woman that's what I'm writing yeah
that's why I looked at you first
he don't he normally does not like me to
tell the story but it's my explanation
on where my hatred please yeah no I
think it's important in Bosnia so our
main mission was there to go get uh war
criminals put them hold on to them until
somebody came and got him and
transported them to the Hague right okay
so like milosevic's karate and all those
guys right we never did get those we
actually ended up capturing a couple
Al-Qaeda guys because Bosnia happened at
I don't know if it still is but it was
an Al-Qaeda training ground a lot of
people didn't know that it was hidden
away
um so anyway
uh I had this interpreter
but since 24 7 we're not hunting down
war criminals you know where we have
other stuff we need to do so my uh my
Colonel decided hey Mac he said you're a
cry or charismatic guy
I'm gonna send you on some PR Duty
you're gonna you're gonna give radio
interviews
I was like
all right so I'd go to these radio
stations in Bosnia yeah well I had to
have an interpreter right yeah yeah so
it was it was a female 20-something
right Bosnian
um and she she ended up being actually
my my team's interpreter and uh sweet
girl very pretty
um but very very European and when I say
that it's not it it sounds like I'm
being judgy and I'm really trying not to
I'm just trying to put it into a frame
of mind where
a lot of your European Muslims are not
as Orthodox as say like Afghan Muslims
you know or or Saudi Muslims or
something like that they're a lot more
just Carefree okay about things
um and that is in no way a judgment is
just trying to give an explanation
understood you know she didn't wear her
job uh she you know she went out she
dated guys and you know her family was
more with production she was we actually
she took her took us she took my team to
her house I mean we met her family and
wonderful people
wonderful people now I'm saying this
remember that
and this girl
we had so much respect for her she took
care of us you know
and we took care of her to to to put it
into a frame of mind within Bosnian this
is what caused such a problem for when
they had the Civil War and stuff
where there's Serbian Villages within
Bosnia yep okay
and we went into one of the Serbian
villages to try to get some information
I sat down and met with the police chief
there
and my interpreters here he's Serbian
she's Bosnian
of course I didn't know exactly what
they were saying but his tone and her
reaction told me that he was not being
very nice right something was up I got
up pulled out my M4 pulled it up so if
you ain't got nothing nice to say you
shut the hell up
just like tell them that because yeah
because I was like she's with me she's
with you yeah
I don't
I I like her but I don't like I hate her
right but she's with me I'm taking care
of her okay
plus I know without her I'm probably not
gonna get out of town so so and my
friends asked if we were sitting in the
chow hall one day and some friends I was
with who's sitting there eating
and uh
we started talking about how much I
hated Muslims because these are part of
the group that's like Dude you need
chill
they said well what about Sarah man you
like Sarah
I said dude I do man she's great I said
man I I do just about anything for her
but there's going to come a time when
she got to go
so what do you mean she's Muslim dude
she gotta go I said but because I do
like her and I do respect her I said I
hope I'm the one that's there to do it
because I'll just put a nine to the base
of her skull and she'll go quick and
painless
but she's still gotta go
that's hatred man I mean that that you
you you can't get any better explanation
on the hatred that I felt in that way to
actually have a desire to to take the
life of someone that I like
you know that's been good to me
that's hatred
I just
I wrestle with that sometimes because
laughs
that's evil man that's that's the
foundation of evil
and I I can't
I don't know I don't know
um
anyway where are we at we're